Will very religious christians outbreed the
atheists? What are the projections
for amish, mormons, catholics in anno domini
2100. I don't know the projections but it's
almost
certain that christians are going to outbreed
atheists because the fertility differentials
are absolutely massive. For any religious
individual of any denomination religiosity
seems
to have these very pronounced natalistic effects.
We have another question, what is our view
on eric kaufman's work? so it fits completely
with the
previous question. So Eric kaufman has a book
Shall the religious
inherit the earth. A few years ago there was
a paper by helmet nyborg and lee ellis,
who showed comprehensively with a large data
set that absolutely
the religious will inherit the earth.
They will. i mean it's impossible for them
not to, they have so many more children than
the
non-religious than the atheists.
Also don't forget gerhard meisenberg, underappreciated.
He put out a paper in which he also produced
these projections showing religiosity
growing as a function of fertility differentials
using the world values survey. Everyone overlooks
that paper.
I see it like this: that that our stress levels
go down because of the industrial revolution
and this
makes us less religious, since religiousness
is associated with stress.
so the more stressed you are, the more religious
you become. And so the society has become
less religious gradually. But while that's
happening, while we are becoming less religious
at the environmental level, we are becoming
more religious at the genetic level due to
differential fertility. And eventually it
reaches a point where the differential
is such that that religiousness pokes through,
and we start to become more religious even
though stress levels are still bottomed out.
And then what will probably happen is the
stress levels will go up
because religiousness is associated with ethnocentrism,
so it could elevate (perhaps) ethnic conflict.
The differential breeding of
religious muslims is very high, it's like
five kids. So I would suspect that we can
expect
religious future, which is exactly what Eric
Kaufmann predicts in his book.
One of the problems is that christianity has
been so debased (despite christians breeding
more than than
atheists), christianity has been so humiliated,
hasn't it?
Yes, the vitality and vigor of any given religion,
is going to be a function of
the degree to which it is embedded within
a society that is undergoing very very strong
group selection.
Because don't forget religion is an adaptation
to group selection, this was D S Wilson's
argument
he put forward in darwin's cathedral. That
it solves the free-riding problem, that it
makes a virtue out
of ethnocentrism, martyrdom, self-sacrifice,
and it provides people with
monumentalist meaning in their lives, such
that they are happy toiling because they know
ultimately there is a greater good being served
in so doing,
reflected through the success of your nation,
which is in turn a reflection on the glory
of your God.
And if a society is falling apart through
a regime of chronic, persistent, individual-level
selection,
as we are living through at the moment, the
religious institutions will change to adapt
to that reality.
They will become pushers of whatever fashionable
bromides are going.
They will drop all of the group-selected trappings
of the religion, retreat from their basic
function, essentially.
It's not those types of religious people that
are breeding heavily.
Yes, that's right. It's people who are more
old-style, old-book type.
This is the kind of religion we were selected
for. Religion is 40% genetic, it has a fertility
advantage as well.
And so this implies it's something that's
been selected for in itself, rather than simply
a bundle of things that have been selected
for that come together as religion.
The paper The Mutant Says in His Heart There
Is No God, claims that we were selected for
this very specific form of religiosity,
for a moral God whom we worship collectively.
And it seems that deviations from that is
associated with low fertility, and holding
to that associated with high fertility.